grève symbolique d urgence aujourd'hui
selon les syndicats 7 un succès au
mouvement des médecins pour dire la
colère devant le manque d'effectifs et
de titulaire la pression à gauche de
robert hue à la veille de la
manifestation nationale des chômeurs
l'augmentation des minima sociaux
soutenus par le leader du parti
communiste serait à l'étude
l'innocence bafouée avec le témoignage
de marie laforêt qui avait enfoui dans
sa mémoire le viol dont elle a été
victime à l'âge de trois ans pour la
première fois la police des polices les
centres et une caméra enquête dans ce
journal à l'igpn un organisme dont la
discrétion est la règle d'or enfin à la
veille du départ de la course new york
san francisco surnommée la route de l'or
en direct des états unis la navigatrice
isabelle autissier madame monsieur
bonsoir ouvrons ce journal avec la
situation dans les services d'urgences
en france manque de médecins manquent de
titulaire pour une profession qui a
décidé de dire aujourd'hui sa colère
grève symbolique d'une heure dans la
plupart des services
l'exemple à l'hôpital de poissy avec
jean daniel flaysakier il est 9 heures
du matin le service des urgences de
poissy n'est plus en grève comme partout
en france ici pendant une heure on n'a
pas assuré les soins non urgents
un mouvement purement symbolique dont
personne n'aura pas t'y mets un
mouvement destiné à faire savoir que les
urgences souffre voici n'échappe pas à
la règle
beaucoup de monde pas assez de personnel
et des patients qui doivent être très
patient c'est toujours trop long surtout
quand on a quand on est mais c'est où
quand on a un enfant qui aime allah dit
l'autre on est on est en moyenne c'est
combien de
mieux d'attendre comme un joli kallas a
fallu deux heures c'est la belle avant
c'était sympa la 20 minutes un quart
d'heure vingt minutes ça c'est très bien
d'autres disent rien qui comprennent
mais qui ne comprennent pas qu'ils
râlent
si tu vois je réponse oui si on attend
autant dans un service d'urgence et
parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de médecins
un mal chronique est généralisée on
estime à l'heure actuelle qui nous
manque
entre 1500 à 2500 médecins pour
correctement prendre en charge les
urgences
il note dans un hôpital comme le vante
par exemple il manque du monde à aux
urgences on peut dire qu'il nous manque
trois 3 postes de médecins proposent de
médecins on est trois médecins
équivalents temps plein à trois temps
plein dans ce service pour faire tourner
un service où on voit trente six mille
patients par an alors si les urgences
tournent 24 heures sur 24 c'est en
partie grâce à des médecins vacataires
comme le dr de danton ses médecins
peuvent assurer jusqu'à dix gardes de
nuit par mois sans aucune sécurité
d'emploi ni promesse d'embauché une
précarité très répandu dans les hôpitaux
français en faisant une moyenne de
minimum 60 heures par semaine je leur
coûte douze à treize mille francs par
mois le remède au mal des urgences est
connu il faut beaucoup d'argent
un remède que depuis des années les
pouvoirs publics ont administré au congo
je vous propose maintenant de nous
rendre au centre radio maritime de saint
lys qui depuis quelques minutes à peine
ne répond plus aux liens chaleureux
entre les navigateurs et la terre
pratiqué par des milliers de marins
depuis un demi siècle
il a fermé c'est toute une page de la
vie quotidienne des marins qui est
tournée christophe la rocca gilbert
usant
la station est fini complètement
monsieur on termine complètement ce soir
c'est fermé pour toujours certains
aujourd'hui avait du mal à le croire
saint-lys radio c'était depuis 1948 le
lien privilégié des marins avec la terre
ces grandes antennes perdu dans la
campagne près de toulouse permettait aux
marins de rester en contact avec leurs
proches célèbres ou anonymes saint lys a
retenu leur voix à l'autre là c'était
quelqu'un de très chaleureux de très
bavard et je me rappelle on parlait
assez souvent ce soir tard après avoir
épuisé le trafic
il nous avait demandé on avait commencé
du reste avec d'autres opérateurs à lui
apprendre le morse et puis bon ben c'est
vrai que hélas disparu tragiquement avec
manu rêve à manureva le radeau de guy
delage mais aussi et surtout des
milliers de bateaux anonyme
les habitués de la mer était heureux de
trouver à saint lys une voix chaleureuse
quand le temps se gâte et que la
solitude se fait lourde aujourd'hui les
témoignages de sympathie affluaient de
partout
moi je suis tombé copain avec un certain
nombre d'opérateurs à saint lys
parce qu on a discuté d'autres choses et
puis on communiquait aussi sur autre
chose et nous apporter un petit peu de
réconfort psychologique surtout quand on
est un solitaire mais aujourd'hui plus
d'opérateurs c'est le satellite qui
prend le relais le satellite plus
confortable mais à l'équipement bien
plus onéreux
ce soir ce sont les plaisanciers les
moins fortunés qui pleure le plus saint
lys et sa petite voix désuète qui sent
les moulins 1 litre à piau service radio
téléphonique avec des navires en mer
c'est de transmission est effectué au
niveau normal de parole l'enfance en
danger l'enfant se bafouée avec cette
semaine la révélation de marie laforêt
qui veut parler pour avertir et raconter
le long combat de l'enfant pour échapper
à la culpabilité l'actrice et chanteuse
en effet choisi de dire quel âge de
trois ans elle avait été violée à
plusieurs reprises par un voisin se
souvenir censuré pendant des années a
ressurgi vers la quarantaine voici
comment la mémoire peut différer un
traumatisme témoignages et explications
avec anne 15 berger et philippe
deslandes
lorsque sur le crime la mémoire jette un
voile il n'y a pas d'image même plus de
mots pour dire
et lorsque le temps réveille le souvenir
du viol c'est avec une extrême clarté
j'ai revécu très exactement tout ce qui
était vrai s'était passé le nom du
monsieur son costume ça sa manière de
faire de tout tout est revenu en même
temps il m'a été impossible d'en parler
pendant d'abord trois jours et trois
nuits de crises de larmes mais après
très difficilement j'arrivais à donner
des bribes
c'est un fait que j'ai reçu en pleine
figure
vous ne vous ne pouvez en aucun cas le
confondre avec autre chose ni avec une
prémonition n'y avait qu'un une histoire
de confusion mentale il s'agit pas de
confusion mentale
au contraire vous êtes d'une d'une
excessive précision comment vous pouvez
expliquer que votre mémoire est enfoui
de si longues années cet événement là je
crois que ces deux mêmes domaines que
l'autisme l'évanouissement le coma il y
à un épisode douloureux et on va décider
d'y mettre fin il n'y a plus alors de
verrous ni de censure à cette enfance
bafouée du huis clos intérieure va
bientôt surgir la véritable histoire qui
seule permet de se reconstruire
le souvenir est resté dans l'inconscient
il n'a pas été détruit et parfois c'est
à la faveur de lien associatif c'est à
dire que de deux souvenirs en souvenir
ou fini par se rapprocher de l'événement
traumatique
ça veut dire peut-être aussi que la
personne était prête à ce moment-là à
l'affronter alors que jusque là elle ne
l'était pas
commence alors pour la victime la longue
reconquête de son identité
retrouvez-les estime de soi et
poursuivre le vrai coupable lorsqu'il
est encore temps car le délai de
prescription est là c'est en matière de
crimes sexuels va jusqu'à dix ans après
la majorité aux deux la justice ne peut
être rendue
c'est vrai qu'il faut rallonger la
prescription mais l'effet pervers de
cette très longue prescription c'est
qu'on ne va pas pouvoir prouver
facilement les témoins sont morts ils
ont disparu ces faits là se passe dans
le domaine privé
or si on ne peut pas prouver on ne peut
pas condamner et si la personne est
acquitté la victime est deux fois
victime ou s'il ya un non lieu
elle dit mais alors c'est qu'on ne me
croie pas c'est que j'ai menti elles se
trouvent deux fois vie
lorsque la justice impose des limites la
mémoire elle demande du temps c'est au
creux de sept fractures que se perdent
les réponses aux crimes sexuels alors
qu'aujourd'hui le plan anti violence
dans les écoles rentrer en application
je me propose de suivre sur le terrain
une relation qui se crée entre écoles
police et justice
à l'intérieur des établissements
scolaires pour lutter notamment contre
le racket reportage dans un collège
parisien jean bernard schmidt frédéric
basket d'accord d'ailleurs un numéro de
téléphone
si vous apprennent pour nous appeler il
mangeait avec en main un document
d'information éditée par la préfecture
de police qu'il distribue depuis deux
semaines aux élèves
ces policiers sont venus dans cette
classe de 6ème avec un objectif parler
de prévention raquette principal blême
de discussion les vols dont peuvent être
victimes les enfants
le racket sujet souvent tabou la mission
de ces correspondants scolaire faire
prendre conscience aux enfants des
dangers qu'ils peuvent courrier la
police et apparemment le message passe
comme raquette ce qui fait ce qui est le
plus dommage c'est que c'est la peur de
racket c'est un petit peu la peur pousse
monde parce que le racketteur celle de
la menace là la sésamie là tout ça m'a
appris qu'il faut voir a quitté ckoi
est-ce que c'est après défendre aussi
contre les racketteurs quel que soit ce
n'est certes qu'une opération de
sensibilisation l'objectif est d'aider
les enfants à vaincre la loi du silence
à force par me parler
beaucoup de peinture déposée chose qui
existait avant qu'ils ne se faisait pas
je vois koné site le plus en plus les
gens les parents les jeunes à porter
plainte contre leur enquête dans les
quartiers les plus difficiles de la
capitale la collaboration voulue par le
gouvernement entre écoles police et
justice s'intensifie ces agents chargés
de la prévention vont aujourd'hui
jusqu'à rencontrer quatre classes par
jour il ya tout juste un mois dans un
commissariat lyonnais un policier avait
abattu un jeune homme avec un fusil à
pompe écroués dans les jours qui ont
suivi l'homme est passé aujourd'hui
devant le conseil de discipline de la
police qui à l'unanimité a réclamé la
révocation du policier je vous propose
donc maintenant de découvrir au
quotidien l'igpn la police des polices
un organisme chargé de surveiller et
d'enquêté au sein même de ses troupes
une institution dont le secret est l'une
des règles d'or c'est la première fois
qu'une caméra pénètre dans ses locaux
reportage
michèle fines pierre laurent constants
derrière la porte à claude les locaux de
la police des polices oui je me rendais
au feeling sans fin de discipline
la mission dans quelle émission de
discipline qui exercent qui s'exerce on
les appelle familièrement les boeufs
carottes car ils ont dit on l'habitude
de faire mijoter leurs collègues
au cours des auditions hurle un
connaisseur du cabinet centrale de
discipline
un petit local de l'urd a vu l'année
dernière l'administration à sanctionner
plus de 2500 policiers en service
combien en garde à vue un policier de la
même manière pour mettons en garde à vue
n'importe quel citoyen il y a que de
procédure pénale on applique le code de
procédure pénale pour l'ensemble des
personnes gardées à vue y compris pour
les
si aucune raison que des régimes
particuliers ce sont des bureaux des
officiers au cabinet centrale de
dissiper nous avait surtout des
officiers de police qui sont tous ceux
ce n'est pas des faux n'est ce pas
monsieur relativement anciens docks de
grade élevé dans l'eure dans leur corps
et qui ont surtout l'expérience
nécessaire il est recommandé d'avoir
quand même à l'inspection générale c'est
donc ça pourrait appeler l'igpn aussi
bien les éléphants non c'est pas du tout
pour ça c'est que pendant quelques
fonctionnaires mais il faut pas
généraliser qui arrivait en fin de
carrière dans la section ça représente
une minorité dans l'effectif de l'igpn
et ce sont d'excellents fonctionnaires
qui ont toute leur place dans la section
générale qui remplissent des missions
éminente bon vous connaissez ce que nous
dit ce n'est sûr mais à titre de rappel
jean marie carrière et commissaire
divisionnaire depuis dix ans à l'igpn
il est là sous réaliser un audit du
commissariat de lens mais il ne s'agit
pas de ballons trop laid mais de faire
un bilan et de données qui savent lire
un contrôle de la conformité
tous les transports vous saurez tout un
gain ou moins bien de ce que nous
apercevoir nous ce que nous constatons
un
vous pouvez me montrer l'origine 31 s'il
vous plaît personnes
l'exposition de police judiciaire ap les
registres de garde à vue mais pas
partout en regard de tous ces traits
cana certaine méfiance est normal le bon
fonctionnaire a toujours peur de se
tromper qu'ils soient policiers ou pas
au début il faut détendre l'atmosphère
et jouer la franchise et à la faire mais
ça se passe mais généralement guère vous
analysez les yeux sur des objectifs
précis
jean varlet carrière restera trois
semaines au commissariat de lens
l'audit est l'une des missions majeures
de l'igpn
en france chaque l'hôtel de police et
contrôlé environ anglais 500 importante
saisie de cigarettes de contrebande à la
frontière franco-italienne 10 tonnes
répartis dans plus d'un millier de
cartons au milieu d'emballage de
produits alimentaires ont été
découvertes ces cigarettes étaient
destinés au marché clandestin espagnol à
la veille de la manifestation nationale
des chômeurs martine aubry sur le
terrain à lille a rencontré cet après
midi des chômeurs alors qu'il
remplissait des formulaires de demande
l'aide d'urgence le mécanisme est bien
en place a déclaré le ministre de
l'emploi
par ailleurs martine aubry qui est
également première adjointe au maire de
lille a assisté à une réunion de la
cellule d'urgence du nord et pendant ce
temps là à paris une cinquantaine de
chômeurs continue d'occuper normale sup
soutenu par autant d'étudiants et puis
occupation surprise d'une autre grande
école des chômeurs dans l'amphithéâtre
de sciences po reportage damien thévenot
et françois granier par le rendez vous
était fixé devant l'école normale occupé
depuis mercredi par une quarantaine de
chômeurs rassemblement pacifique à
l'appel d'associations 200 emplois
auxquels s'étaient joints des
intellectuels
et un événement sans précédent dans
l'histoire une exception historique s'il
vous plaît très rapidement les
manifestants ont décidé une action
surprise
comme toujours le lieu gardé secret
jusqu'au dernier moment pour devancer la
police cet après midi ces sciences po
que les chômeurs ont choisi d'investir
en force
finalement une cinquantaine de chômeurs
ont pu pénétrer à l'intérieur du
bâtiment discussions et débats
improvisés entre futurs énarques et sans
emploi ont recoupé le vent ça fait neuf
mois pour manger vêtements jouets ou
paris pour ma piégeux
je comprends à voir mais j'arrive pas à
penser une solution d'accord ou pas en
tout cas les étudiants ont apprécié
l'initiative des chômeurs c'est prouver
la réalité rue chaude c'est bien ce soir
les chômeurs vont passer la nuit à
sciences po prêt pour la grande
manifestation prévue demain
après les actions spontanées des
chômeurs vient maintenant l'heure de la
stratégie stratégie organisée par les
associations qui dirige le mouvement
avec notamment à leur tête claire
veillée une militante chevronnée qui est
devenu l'une des interlocutrices des
pouvoirs publics olivier caroff
dominique bonnet on ce matin chez moi
5h30 il ya les journaux viennent à
l'épaule temps d'y aller
le gym on
à un emploi du temps de ministre pour
celle qui depuis à moi empêche justement
certains ministres de dormi à 47 ans
claire villiers fait partie des
principaux responsables du mouvement des
chômeurs en colère c'est tout s'organise
dans ses 80 mètres carrés très
encombrées le quartier général de
l'association ac les rôles sont bien
répartis
christophe aguiton l'ancien touristes
supervise les occupations de locaux
claire villiers qui a fait ses premières
armes dans les jeunesses ouvrières
chrétiennes se chargent des
manifestations moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
parce que je suis content après des
glissements et c'est bien pour garder le
contrôle du mouvement que claire vignier
se rend dans les locaux occupés de la
capitale depuis trois jours 50
manifestants ont envahi l'école normale
supérieure peu de chômeurs sur le toit
mais beaucoup de jeunes militants
parfois tentés d'en découdre avec des
forces de l'ordre omniprésentes comme le
sparadrap du capitaine haddock
hier on sait jamais où ils vont aller
aussi avait souffert en tout cas ils
sont toujours visibles
à vous vous avez une info vise à sion de
plus en plus difficile à gérer à mesure
que le mouvement s'étend 4 de faire du
jeu social alors que les flics l'autre
un lieu où on a décidé d'en tu fais pour
faire une ag de lutte et vous voulez
faire la paix sociale etc la légion
parce que vous contrôlez plus vraiment
le voilà ce qu'ils veulent pas sortir
ebay vient tous les jours enfin pas le
temps de s'attarder claire vignier
encore beaucoup de problèmes à régler
pour la manifestation de samedi
au fond dans cette manif yehuda ben
laden les assedic et en cette banderole
klervi niel aveux pour une raison bien
précise la cfdt c'est son syndicat
depuis plus de 20 ans elle y militent
dans une fraction résolument hostile à
nicole notât
au coeur des revendications des chômeurs
depuis plusieurs semaines l'augmentation
des minima sociaux dans un premier temps
le gouvernement avait écarté l'hypothèse
cet après midi pourtant matignon parle
d'un éventuel relèvement mais pas avant
l'an prochain les explications
nécessaires de ce que sont ses revenus
minimums et leurs enjeux financiers
yannick letranchant les minima sociaux
qui les touchent 6 millions de personnes
aujourd'hui en france les minima sociaux
qu'est ce que c'est le rmi le revenu
minimum d'insertion l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique
le minimum vieillesse ce sont les plus
connus mais il ya aussi le minimum
invalidité l'allocation adultes
handicapés l'allocation de parent isolé
et l'allocation d'assurance veuvage et
l'allocation d'insertion le rmi 2429
francs pour une personne seule 3644
francs pour un couple
un million d'allocataires l'allocation
de solidarité spécifique la ss est
versée aux chômeurs en fin de droit et
aux chômeurs de plus de 50 ans dans
certaines conditions 2264 francs maximum
cinq cent vingt mille bénéficiaires et
cetera et cetera
le relèvement des minimas sociaux une
revendication c'est la revendication
numéro 1 des associations de chômeurs
revalorisation demandée plus 1500 francs
minima sociaux l'art
pons du gouvernement pour lionel jospin
un relèvement immédiat coûterait trop
cher pour lui c'est incompatible avec
nos contraintes budgétaires
autre danger relever les minima sociaux
c'est pour le gouvernement enlever toute
incitation au travail et qu'il soit
ainsi plus rentable de toucher les
allocations minimum que de travail
minima sociaux un vaste chantier
un chantier sur lequel planche matignon
pas de relèvement immédiat en vue mais
une réflexion pour repenser ses minima
sociaux et les rendre plus justes pour
les experts du cercle associations les
conditions de vie des six millions de
personnes touchant les minima sociaux se
sont dégradées depuis 1983
la plupart des allocataires vivent au
dessous du seuil de pauvreté 3316 francs
par personne et par mois
robert hue met la barre à gauche cet
après midi le secrétaire national du
parti communiste appelle énergiquement
les nageuses pas entendre le mouvement
des chômeurs et à infléchir sa politique
sociale françoise david
philippe lui dit on vers une infirme
tout premier ministre qu'il est lionel
jospin ne sait pas tout du mouvement des
chômeurs alors le dirigeant communiste
lui a confié ce secret qui peut paraître
paradoxal la révolte des sans emploi est
une chance pour le pays et à l'intimité
entre la gauche face à la droite et
aussi ntf la gauche
aurait-elle à s'inquiéter d'un tel
mouvement dans ce qu'ils expriment de
profond de l'exigence de dignité et de
citoyenneté qu'il représente
certainement pas la chance de la gauche
pour réussir c'est de savoir entendre ce
que disent les hommes et les femmes
engagées dans ce mouvement de fond un
mouvement dans lequel souligné son
dirigeant le parti communiste se sent
comme un poisson dans l'eau
il n'y aura pas de grand écart du parti
communiste dans l'hérault béru d'aller
plus loin
incontestablement la le compte n'y est
pas le compte n'y est pas sa déception
n'est pas un jugement négatif
c'est dire que de premiers pas ont été
franchis
de premières mesures ont été engagées
mais qu'il faut aller plus loin
augmentation des minima sociaux
augmentation du smic amélioration du
projet sur les 35 heures notamment sur
les heures supplémentaires
le parti communiste aujourd'hui à poser
ses exigences enfin dominique strauss
kahn a annoncé cet après midi un coup de
pouce pour les familles bénéficiaires du
prêt à l'accession à la propriété en
fait cinq cent mille familles
bénéficieront d'un taux plafonné à 7 %
et les taux progressifs seront ramenés à
1 to fix préavis de grève pour le jour
de l'inauguration du stade de france à
saint-denis c'est la fédération autonome
des agents de conduite qui a lancé un
mot d'ordre à la sncf par ailleurs la
cgt la cgt métro rer de la ratp a déposé
un autre préavis mais rien n'est fait
pour l'instant à bruxelles manifestation
d'anciens ouvriers de renault vilvorde
au salon auto un moment symbolique au
stand de l'entreprise française cette
manifestation coïncidait avec la
convocation du pdg louis chenevert
devant la justice belge mais finalement
le dossier ne sera traité que dans
quelques semaines
lionel jospin sur internet le premier
ministre présenté aujourd'hui un plan
d'action pour encourager la france ou
multimédia un projet ambitieux
culturellement et qui devrait en premier
touché les administrations donnant ainsi
l'exemple aux états unis car la teneur
condamné à mort pour un double meurtre
et qui devrait être exécutée le 3
février prochain car la teneur bénéficie
désormais d'un soutien sans condition
depuis qu'elle s'est convertie au
christianisme maryse burgot un visage
serein
étonnamment apaisé celui d'une condamnée
à mort interviewé en ce moment sur
toutes les grandes chaînes de télévision
américaines
je fais confiance en dieu il fera de moi
ce qu'il voudra et quoi que ce soit je
serais d'accord car la toque heures s'en
remet donc à dieu pour les quinze
derniers jours qui lui restent à vivre
son exécution par injection est prévue
le 3 février prochain
en attendant dans sa prison du texas
elle reçoit les journalistes et sont
calmes impressionne
pourquoi vous ne supplier pas pour qu'on
vous laisse vivre parce que je ne veux
pas ma vie est entre les mains de dieu
il va prendre soin de moi on l'aura
compris car la teneur et chrétiennes en
prison elle a même épousé son pasteur et
lui a pardonné son effroyable geste de
personnes assassinées à coups de piolet
il ya 14 ans c'était pour de l'argent et
parce qu'elle parle de dieu sur toutes
les télévisions une partie de l'amérique
chrétienne se mobilisent et demande que
l'exécution soit suspendue que la peine
soit commuée
mais sur cnn carla explique qu'elle n'y
crois pas malgré tout cela je crois
qu'ils ne laisseront pas une femme comme
moi échappé à la peine de mort demain
cette religieuse américaine ira
manifester au texas avec d'autres
chrétiens et plusieurs associations
internationales abolitionniste pour que
carla ne soit pas exécutée helen prejean
visite régulièrement des condamnés à
mort en prison
quand vous voyez cela de près vous
réalisez que c'est juste une imitation
de la violence et que notre société doit
abolir cela le destin de carling est
maintenant entre les mains d'une
commission des pardons mais selon les
experts les chances de carla d'échapper
à cette pièce sont minces le texas est
l'état américain où l'on exécute
aujourd'hui le plus dans le couloir de
la mort carla s'en remet donc plus que
jamais à dieu pur produit de la
dictature argentine dans les années 80
celui qu'on appelait l'ange blond de la
mort a reconnu avoir participé à de
nombreuses tortures et exécutions et
alfredo astiz ne regrette rien condamné
en france pour l'assassinât de deux
religieuses l'ancien capitaine de marine
est mis aux arrêts pour 60 jours richard
binet
on l'appelait l'ange blond un ange déchu
réapparu hier à la une de la presse
argentine le capitaine astiz un ancien
tortionnaire qui fort de l'impunité dont
jouissent aujourd'hui encore les
militaires argentins se permet de
déclarer les juntes militaires ont été
lâche car elles n'ont pas eu le courage
de dire qu'il fallait fusillé tous les
opposants
je suis aujourd'hui l'homme
techniquement le mieux préparé pour tuer
un politique ou un journaliste ni
regrets ni état d'âme
un chien de guerre qui durant les années
de dictature de 73 à 83 n'a eu d'autre
mission que de traquer de tuer les
opposants au régime
6500 selon lui dont ces deux religieuses
françaises assassinées en 1977 à la
suite d'atroces tortures en 1985 comme
d'autres militaires le capitaine astiz
avait été condamné puis amnistié
il s'agissait alors d'en finir avec
cette période noire de l'histoire du
pays
l'argentine n'en finit pas de pourfendre
ses vieux démons
le président carlos menem a ordonné au
chef de la marine la plus grande
sévérité 60 jours d'arrêt ont été
prononcées contre l'ancien capitaine
mais il est vrai que quatorze ans après
le retour de la démocratie en argentine
il n'était plus question de juger un
homme mais des mots en turquie le parti
islamiste de l'ancien premier ministre
harb à cannes a été dissous aujourd'hui
par la cour constitutionnelle
l'émissaire bakhan déchu de son mandat
de député est interdit de politique
pendant cinq ans
cette décision prise par la plus haute
instance judiciaire justification l'
atteinte à la laïcité de l'état par
crainte que d'éventuels débordements les
mesures de sécurité ont été multipliés
dans les grandes villes de turquie
alors que l'ex premier ministre
annonçait que le mouvement islamiste
grandir à cette citation du sport avec
les championnats d'europe de patinage
cet après-midi la française surya bonaly
tient la deuxième place dans le
programme court hier candeloro n'a pu
atteindre le podium il termine cinquième
mais son interprétation de d'artagnan a
été un succès et yann lavoix
jamais depuis l'interprétation du
parrain philippe candeloro n'avait
semblé autant à son aise dans la peau
d'un personnage candeloro et d'artagnan
n'ont fait qu'un hier soir un programme
éblouissant de très loin le plus
original de tous un programme où
philippe a placé huit triples sauts qui
ont séduit le public et les juges aussi
avec l'obtention d'un 6-0 aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'au jour dans ma carrière
parce que c'est mon premier set zéro de
note artistique donc jeudi en
compétition internationale
donc je connais ce tueur
m
des doutes ont plané sur sa présence
jusqu'à la dernière minute
surya bonaly qui souffre toujours d'un
talon a finalement exécuté un programme
court parfait
surya a pris la deuxième place et un
septième titre européen et donc à sa
portée de main si sa douleur ne
l'empêchent pas de tenter et de réussir
les différents triple saut prévu dans
son programme libre
c'est moins bien parti en revanche pour
vanessa gusmeroli révélation du patinage
français et européen l'an passé elle
avait obtenu une médaille de bronze
déception aujourd'hui avec cette
mauvaise réception qui lui vaut la 8e
place du programme court en australie à
perth en natation le français
jean-christophe sarnin médaille d'argent
au 200 m brasse c'est l'américain kurt
grotte qui a remporté la finale du 200
mètres aux championnats du monde de
natation et le français donc été ratés
ont terminé deuxièmes avec deux minutes
13 secondes
c'est demain le départ de la première
édition de la course new york san
francisco nous y reviendrons avec
isabelle autissier vous êtes à quelques
heures de cette compétition via le cap
horn qui devrait durer au moins deux
mois
mais si vous voulez bien voyons tout de
suite le portrait de l'un de vos
concurrents vous parliez le vainqueur de
la dernière route du café
yves perrier à marin pas comme les
autres un extraterrestre christophe
duchiron et frédérick basile alors que
personne ne contestera qu'il ya dans
cette ville comme un petit côté
avant-garde remarquer le bateau d'yves
parlier a lui aussi des allures un peu
futuriste l'amérique celle du cinéma des
soucoupes volantes et des
extraterrestres yves parlier dans le
monde de la voile depuis des années déjà
on l'appelle l'extraterrestre tout ça
parce qu'il a souvent démontré qu'il
avait un sens marin venu d'ailleurs on
est quelque part des extraterrestres
puisque on a plus souvent sur l'eau sur
la terre et puis sur l'eau on est
vraiment au milieu de l'univers on est
projeté au milieu des étoiles on est
tout à fait sensible mouvement des
astres
le vaisseau de l'extra terrestre pendant
le dernier vendée globe
d'habitude l'extraterrestre navigue seul
mais pour new york san francisco
il embarque avec lui trois terriens pour
un long voyage de l'atlantique au
pacifique en passant par le cap horn
deux mois d'aventuré venir une fois dans
sa vie à broadway c'est aussi une
aventure broadway une sorte de soucoupe
multicolores broadway le centre de
manhattan qui se prend un peu pour le
centre de l'univers
depuis qu'il est à new york
l'extraterrestre traverse broadway pour
aller jusqu'à son hôtel chaque fois il
en a pris plein les mirettes de la
démesure new yorkaise
ici il ya une telle dimension rien qu'à
voir la hauteur des immeubles
ces lignes est
bon quand on arrive de petit village de
paris tout ça est une échelle différente
au maire il ya aussi des grandes
échelles nous on est tout petit quand on
voit la taille de ce qu'est l'océan
pacifique
c'est une immensité où pendent et jouent
à des jeux on peut naviguer sans jamais
voire de terre la tête dans les étoiles
les pieds sur l'eau allô la terre demain
par l'extra-terrestre reprend la mer
et en direct de new york nous rejoignent
or isabelle autissier bonsoir vous
partez dangereux bonjour vous partez oui
bonjour pour vous vous partez donc comme
au siècle dernier sur les traces des
chercheurs d'heure avec cette difficulté
majeure qu'est le cap horn c'est un
nouveau défi dont vous aviez besoin
oui moi j'ai la chance d'avoir déjà
triste parcours ya quatre ans puisque je
suis la détentrice officiel du record en
62 jours donc c'est un magnifique
parcours et puis il ya une vraie
histoire humaine parce que vous lisiez
c'est l'histoire les chercheurs d'or
c'est l'histoire des clippers les gens
qui passent le cap horn à l'envers et je
crois que les marins sont assez
sensibles en général à leurs origines
n'en passait lors du vendée globe on
s'en souvient vous étiez partis à leur
recherche du canadien gerry roufs est-ce
que depuis votre sentiment concernant
les courses en solitaire a changé c'est
un peu pourquoi vous avez près le projet
d'une compétition en équipage non il n'a
pas vraiment changé puisque je vais
refaire des compétitions en solitaire
après celle là mais je crois que c'est
bien alterner parce qu'on a des bateaux
que en solitaire on veut pas mené à cent
pour cent
et là je crois qu'avec un équipages
aguerris on va vraiment pouvoir pousser
les bateaux très loin donc sportivement
ça va être serré et passionnant
alors j'imagine que pour une traversée
de plus de deux mois le choix des
coéquipiers délicat y est le sport mais
il est aussi l'intimité de la vie au
quotidien
oui c'est presque premier critère en fat
1 il faut évidemment avoir des bons
marins mais ça je crois qu'en france on
en a pas mal mais il faut des gens qui
humainement soit capable de vivre cette
espèce de huis clos de deux mois
l'intérieur de notre de notre habitat
que je dirais c'est environ 4 mètres
carrés et on est en permanence sous le
regard des autres donc malgré la fatigue
la pression de la course
la tension les problèmes il faut que
l'équipage restent complètement sud et
qu'on est toujours du plaisir à naviguer
ensemble et et envie de faire marcher le
bateau à fond et et ça c'est un peu un
salon le veuille et quel est votre état
d'esprit à quelques heures la du départ
moi je suis ravi de faire ce magnifique
parcours de course
et puis c'est vrai que c'est beau d'être
ici d'être à manhattan d'avoir les
bateaux au pied des bulles dit
notre ligne de départ c'est la statue de
la liberté donc c'est quand même quelque
chose quoi je crois que nous permet le
bateau est bien prêt l'équipage sont en
super bien donc on est tout à fait prêt
à aller en découlent mais quelle
nouvelle performance vous allez en
découdre sur 20 pouvez-vous obtenir ben
on peut espérer battre ce record de 62
jours commandé plusieurs bateaux on peut
espérer gagner la course et de challenge
un petit peu différent et puis pourquoi
pas essayer d'établir des nouveaux
records de vitesse en 24 heures ou des
choses comme ça dernière question au
passage isabelle autissier quel livre
quel type de distraction amené vous à
bord alors il ya pas grand chose parce
que quand même l'énergie c'est pour le
bateau et le temps c'est pour le bateau
mais en équipage ya quand même des
petits breaks
donc on a de la musique c'est très varié
on a ici à new york on a acheté pas mal
de choses qu'on connaît pas donc on va
essayer
et puis on a quelques romans quelques
quelques petits romans assez variés 1
pour se distraire un petit peu pour pour
se relaxer un peu de temps en temps ça
permet de recréer une petite intimité
par tournis merci en tout cas isabelle
autissier d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et bien sûr nous suivons la
course avec beaucoup d'attention
une histoire dans la pure tradition
british l'humour anglais et le flair des
meilleurs limiers pour retrouver en
cavale les deux cochons qui ont réussi
une spectaculaire évasion une trappe
une traque qui a tenu en haleine
l'angleterre toute entière et l énarque
rassurez vous cette truie porté en
triomphe et seulement anesthésié elle
peut se vanter en tout cas d'avoir écrit
l'une des plus glorieuses pages de
l'histoire des cochons dans le royaume
il l'histoire commence ici sur les bords
de cette rivière deux cochons s'échappe
de l'abattoir auquel on les destine avis
de recherche
la police est sur les dents et la traque
passionne le pays
de leur hélicoptère les chaînes de
télévision locales is même le fourrer
dans lequel les deux fuyards sont sans
doute cash cameramen et photographes
font le siège du village et la nounou de
le voir hier soir enfin en pleine
interview l'une détruit à localiser
voilà voilà mais le cochon est habile
s'échappe une nouvelle fois et force
l'admiration du peuple tout entier à la
une ce matin toute la presse un plan les
autorités de ne pas abattre les fugitifs
à l'heure des oeufs et du véhicule en
direct sur la bbc
l'envoyé spécial confirme en retenant un
sourire que l'assaut est imminent
il faudra encore plusieurs heures aux
spécialistes pour endormir à distance le
cochon mettre fin au suspense et pouvoir
enfin crier victoire
nous avons réussi à lui envoyer une
fléchette anesthésiante elle a vacillé
et nous avons pu l'attraper
nos deux cochons désormais sacré n'iront
pas à l'abattoir l'opinion ne le
tolérerai pas leurs propriétaires les
vendre au plus offrant
il ya finalement deux façons d'analyser
cette page d'histoire [ __ ] soit
plaindre les anglais mais c'est sans
doute manqué un peu du lourd soit les
envier pour leurs aptitudes collectives
et jusqu'ici inégalée à se moquer d'eux
mêmes ainsi se termine cette édition je
vous appelle les principaux titres grève
symbolique d urgence aujourd'hui selon
les syndicats c'est un succès un
mouvement des médecins pour dire la
colère devant le manque d'effectifs et
de titulaire la pression à gauche de
robert hue à la veille de la
manifestation nationale des chômeurs
l'augmentation des minima sociaux
soutenus par le leader du parti
communiste serait à l'étude voilà la
météo isabelle martinet dans un instant
puis le point route valérie maurice
20h50 nestor burma demain dans thé ou
café
catherine ceylac reçoit le comédien
lambert wilson je vous retrouverai de ma
20h je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2